[Music]
being a traveler and breath of the wild
is tough work the nonstop rain the
constant chores for random people the
never-ending supply of skeleton monsters
there's got to be a place that you can
call your own right well thankfully
there is a way to put a roof over your
head and I'm not just talking about
roadside stables now this process is
gonna take a little bit of cash so if
you're short on rupees go watch our
video on how to make money in the game
but if your pockets are already deep
let's get that house and grow some
equity the first place you'll want to
visit is Hatano village in the east
there you'll find a group of men working
diligently to demolish an old house but
talk to their boss the bolson of bolsa
construction and you can convince him to
sell you the house for the low low price
of 50,000 rupees
okay well you can haggle it down to
three thousand rupees but you'll also
need to bring them 30 bundles of wood as
well so go blow up some trees hock some
gemstones and bam you've got yourself a
brand-new fixer-upper to say the least
initially the house isn't going to feel
too much like a home until you start
decorating it with your own stuff so
talk to bolson again and he'll offer to
build you extras like a bed gear
displays and even a sign with your name
on it they all cost a hundred rupees of
peace so hopefully you've got some money
left over after buying the house after
purchasing every home upgrade and three
of each of the gear mounts bolson
finally gives in and decks out your
bachelor pad with some sweet furniture
Bob Olsen's handiwork looks great it's
not over yet after completing the house
you'll get the quest from the ground up
it'll send you to visit Hudson who's
over in the Acala region working hard on
building an entire town he's gonna need
your help obviously and you're gonna
have to round up some more wood and also
some workers for him with the only
stipulation being that their names must
end in Sun because that's just how the
bolsa construction company rolls
the first guy you need is a strong goron
by the name of Grayson he's hanging out
in the southern mine in the Eldon region
so talk to him and he'll be ecstatic to
join Hudson's crew head back to
Tarrytown and Hudson will request even
more wood if you're having trouble
chopping down trees head to any stable
and you'll typically find an axe perfect
for your lumberjacking needs
you'll also need to find them another
worker and this time you'll want to
recruit ronson a Gerudo she's over right
here you'll repeat this process again
for the retail worker bison and finally
round out the troop with a Zora priest
named captain it'll all culminate in a
wonderful little wedding ceremony for
Hudson but your efforts will be rewarded
with more than just a ribbon to cut and
some rice itas a traveler by the name of
grant a will stop by the completed town
and if you talk to him he'll offer to
sell you pieces of rare high-level gear
granted you've already discovered it so
if he found a piece of barbarian armor
you can actually visit grant a and buy
the remaining two pieces from him and a
someone unreasonable price also if you
manage somehow to break your really nice
weapons such as the Hylian Shield you
can buy that back from him as well it's
a little expensive so don't go around
shield surfing on it all the time unless
you enjoy coughing up several thousand
rupees each time it breaks and there you
have it getting a house in breath of the
wild is as simple as chopping down a
tree selling some more and finding a
priest to Wed the form into a Gerudo
trust me it's a lot easier than it
sounds but if you enjoyed this guide
please subscribe to the gamespot youtube
channel so you can keep up with all the
latest breath of the wild videos